I bet the judge is gonna say all allow
it at some point in this hearing I
guarantee it custody hearing Michael was
pretty worried about challenged action
Your Honor on what grounds hearsay
nice try mrs. Florrick all allowed go
ahead what's called it hey legal eagles
D James Stone here teaching you how to
think like a lawyer today we're gonna
tackle one of the most requested TV
shows out there and that's the Good Wife
as one subscriber put it it is the most
highly rated legal TV show on Rotten
Tomatoes so that should stand for
something and fun fact this is the most
highly requested legal TV show from my
mom so mom I'm finally getting around to
watching The Good Wife I'm doing it for
you and be sure to stick around until
the end where I give this episode of The
Good Wife a grade for legal realism and
how accurate it is to real-life
lawyering so without any further ado
let's get started and dig right into the
Good Wife so we'll need some of you to
help out with the lower profile client
work to free up our top litigators and
you take the witness prep on highway
redistribution Don you take the Brighton
criminal and leash you take the pro bono
everyone else your task is to show
Shiffrin marce our a-game okay okay so
the main character is being assigned
with pro bono work it's not uncommon for
large law firms to get a huge case it's
all hands on deck so they really pull in
all the bodies they can and as the the
lawyer mentioned it does tend to help
with year-end bonuses you work a lot of
billable hours then you'll get a lot of
your end bonuses but the main character
is getting assigned pro bono now pro
bono as you may know is work that's
provided by a law firm for for usually
it's for indigent clients but generally
law firms and sometimes it's mandated by
the state have to do a certain number of
pro bono hours per year it's a way for
the law firm to give back and it's a way
to help those who can't afford really
expensive lawyers and legal services the
lawyers will provide that for free and
that's called pro bono so it looks like
everybody else is being thrown on this
huge
class action whereas the main character
is being given the leftover pro bono
work which is not uncommon so well
speaks highly of you
he says you graduated top of your class
at Georgetown when was this
15 years ago huh huh and you spent two
years at Crozier Abrams and Abbott good
firm will says you clocked the highest
billable hours there why'd you leave
okay
that's a funny throwaway line they're
trying to imply that the main character
is a really diligent worker the way it
works at really big law firms is that
the lawyers are all on salary so at the
end of the year they'll all take home
the same amount except if there's a big
bonus and the way that you get a big
bonus is by clocking a large number of
hours not every hour that you work at a
law firm brings in money to the law firm
or to you personally as a lawyer and
it's only when you're in a much smaller
firm does every hour that you bill go
directly into your pocket in large law
firms all the attorneys billable hours
go into a general pot that's divided
based on the salary and that so they're
saying that she back in the day when she
was in private practice was billing more
than anybody else and in real life
certainly someone has to build more
hours than everybody else
but those numbers can be very very high
somewhere between 2,500 and 3,000
billable hours per year I would say for
every three to four billable hours
you're in the office you're probably not
billing at least one of those hours
whether you're eating lunch or eating
dinner if you're really staying late or
you know you're just taking a break
there are lots of times when you're in
the office and you're not billing so to
build the highest number of billable
hours in a firm is both a badge of honor
and sort of a dubious mark that she's
just a really really hard worker and
good for the firm but not necessarily
good for her personal life so that's an
interesting little tidbit that they
threw in there Jennifer Lewis 26 years
old taught second grade accused of
killing her ex-husband prosecution
thought it was a slam dunk 45 years but
the jury came back last week deadlocked
six
jurors voted to convict six not I'm not
even sure why the state attorney is
retrying except he wants justice he
wants to prove himself so stick with my
strategy from the first trial the police
focused on Jennifer so early in the
investigation they never even looked at
the carjacker what she's talking about
there is that an injury trial you
generally have 12 jurors that's why the
famous movie is called 12 Angry Men
because back in the day they were all
men none of that's obviously not the
case which is a good thing but to
convict someone you have to get all 12
jurors to vote to convict if any one of
those people refuses to vote to convict
the individual it's called a hung jury
now that's different than if all 12 of
the jurors say not to convict or to
acquit then the person just goes free
and there's no way to retry them
generally speaking here obviously at
least one of the jurors found that they
couldn't find her guilty the jury hung
and in that situation the prosecutor has
the ability to retry that individual at
a later time they go through the entire
trial all over again
so that's apparently what's going on
this woman is going to be tried for a
second time where's Diane Diane ask me
to step in for her Jennifer I'm Alicia
Florrick I'm one of the other lawyers
with the firm step in for how long for
the retrial all right
the Criminal Court of Cook County is now
in session the Honorable Judge Richard
cuesta presiding okay let's hear it your
honor refresh your memory the accused
was deemed a flight risk due to an
earlier custody hearing when she
threatened to run off with her dog so
that was a good tactic by the prosecutor
here to take the lead and to educate the
judge usually what happens when you make
an appearance in court is the there is a
huge docket which means that there are
maybe a dozen or so cases that have
hearings to discuss that morning or that
afternoon so number one the judge has a
lot of different cases to deal with
number two it may have been weeks or
months since you were last in the
courthouse especially if you're in state
court where there are just lots and lots
of cases continually churning so now the
judge will probably take a look at the
paperwork before taking the stand but
again there may be a dozen or so cases
that I mean he need he or she needs to
talk about that morning so it's always a
good idea to take the initiative and to
err on the side of providing more
information to the judge than you would
necessarily give to someone who's very
familiar with the case because the judge
might not remember that but I think it's
also to show that the prosecutor is just
kind of taking command and being a jerk
but we'll see
just last week a jury deadlocked on
these murder charges six to six mr.
Browdy now I know our new state's
attorney wants to look tough but why are
you fighting this in reality if a jury
hung six members of the jury to six
meaning six wanted to vote for guilt and
six one and two acquit it's very
unlikely the prosecutor would try that
case again that means you have a really
weak case usually a hung jury is one or
two people which means that with a
different jury pool you have a much
better chance of conviction but if
you're hanging the jury six to six your
case is weak and you probably don't want
to try that one again it's just a waste
of the Court's time at that point if
mrs. Florrick is so intent on getting a
client out why doesn't she agree to a
speedy trial mrs. Florrick
yes your honor the wife of the esteemed
Peter Florrick your husband and I never
quite saw eye-to-eye
Your Honor mr. Florrick don't talk but
if the prosecution thinks that this will
in some way prejudice me against your
client he is sorely mistaken
nice trying to talk so Miss Lewis is
granted pretrial release with electronic
monitoring
she's restricted to temporary housing
attorney's offices and transit in
between and given that this is a rerun
I'll set the trial date for the 25th now
are we all happy good that's a little
more tierce and crotchety than most
judges are gonna be judges know what's
going on for the most part when they see
a new attorney they're likely to be a
little bit more lenient than this judge
here although he is giving the main
character Alicia what she wants so he's
sort of telling her you're gonna win
this one so just be quiet still you want
a command respect from all the lawyers
and so you don't want to be coming off
as a crotchety old person and so that's
a little unrealistic this hearing would
probably take 10 to 15 minutes not 30
seconds but you know the outcome and the
interchange is not crazy a man who came
up to Michael
I didn't see the gun until I saw
Michael's face it was
can you take a break no just if there
was some water
sure Sonia we need some water in here
it's gonna be about five minutes but
then I've got to do is deaf go upstairs
yes that secretary should definitely
support an attorney who is conducting an
interview of a criminal defendant that
is going to trump whatever it is that
she was working on at the moment and
also it's not unusual for secretaries to
support three four and sometimes five
attorneys in a major law firm it's part
of the cost-cutting measures that a lot
of big firms use it's actually not very
difficult for assistance
to provide support to two different
attorneys at the same time and also I
don't know what she was supposed to do
with the deposition that's not something
secretaries to anyway all right so
Alicia's underwater I guess how many
voted for conviction from the start
start eleven what but there was only one
holdout juror number knocking we argued
with her for three days the judge would
only declare us deadlocked if we were
evenly split so some of us agreed to
change our moat to not guilty just to
get out of there if it hadn't been for
juror number nine we would have
convicted she didn't convince us
she exhausted us who that that's
interesting I've never heard of that
happening but that does sound like
something that could happen a judge has
some discretion about when to declare a
particular case as deadlocked so it's
possible that under some circumstances
that the jury just wanted to go home and
so that they would manipulate some of
their votes to make it seem like a
deadlock and everyone can get out of it
that wouldn't be a good thing for our
judicial system but unfortunately that
sounds like something that's possible
because jurors or human beings - oh and
by the way I don't pretend to know the
entire body of American jurisprudence
off the top of my head so I may get
things wrong from time to time if you
see a legal or factual inaccuracy please
leave me a comment
down below but if you do please leave me
a comment in the form of an objection if
you leave an objection I will get to it
and I will either sustain or overrule
your objection I look forward to seeing
them just so I'm clear the defense
experts argue that the gunshot residue
on Jennifer's hands came from the
struggle is that why you held out I
don't know about that I just did to get
a feeling don't I Cyrus okay that sounds
a little crazy that a juror would base
her decision based only on a feeling but
a juror can make their decision based on
just about anything and I remember when
I served on a jury when I was in law
school in a criminal case one of the
jurors refused to convict because she
felt her spirit wouldn't allow it and
she couldn't articulate any other
reasons now the other jurors and I took
a step back we realized the woman was
doing the best that she could and we
talked it through and eventually we all
12 decided on conviction on most of the
counts that issue but people make
different decisions for different
reasons and that's part of the benefit
of the jury system is that we may it's a
check and balance to make sure that the
state doesn't overreach but the downside
is that sometimes you can get some
really strange decision-making going on
behind the curtain of the jury carry the
one in the Brioni what I'm observant yes
the one in the Brioni Briones I see may
the best man win what exactly does he
mean by that what he means is something
I thought we weren't making public what
look we only have one associate position
open so we agree to hire two applicants
and in six months decide which one to
retain so this is a contest between me
and Carrie it was either that or a cage
match that would be highly unusual to
hire two associates and then make them
fight to the death
especially because associates can be
profit centers for large law firms they
work a lot of hours and their salary is
high compared to the national average
but it's actually low compared to the
revenue that they're bringing into the
firm so generally there's no real reason
to make associates fight against each
other if you make an offer to someone at
a large law firm generally they can
stick around for quite some time because
they're good for the firm and and
there's no reason to get rid of them it
would also be highly unusual to tell the
two associates that they're up against
each other you wouldn't want to create
bad blood between those associates and
all the other associates as well so
that's pretty unusual to say that two
associates are going to fight to the
death for their position see the
computer automatically records the
surveillance marks it with date and time
yeah I mean even if the computer did
miss market I make an hourly to earth a
lot and I didn't see no pick up truck
look that's me but 103 just before the
murder
sure lady I like what these attorneys
are doing that they're going to the
scene of the accident and they are
personally investigating good attorneys
conduct written discovery very well
they'll ask questions on paper they'll
get a whole lot of documents but a great
attorney really digs in and checks all
the things that they can to make sure
that their case is as strong as possible
or that the opponent's case is as weak
as possible and going to the scene of an
accident or a crime is a great thing for
an attorney to do not everyone will do
that so I really like what these
attorneys are doing here and they're
really getting into all the details that
they can your name
Sidney Lewis and you are married to the
victim for how long mrs. Lewis two years
until
get out of the well of the court and how
would you describe your husband's
relations but the judge is gonna say oh
I would at some point in this hearing I
guarantee you be hearing Michael was
pretty worried about dejection Your
Honor on what grounds hearsay
nice try mrs. Florrick all allowed go
ahead what's called it he was worried
Jennifer was intent on getting sole
custody
thank you mrs. Louis your witness now
mrs. Lewis you stated that Michael was
worried about Jennifer yet in the week
following action your honor
sustained yeah there was an
argumentative question in your testimony
mrs. Lewis you claim that Jennifer
wanted sole custody
but isn't it connection sustained yeah
argumentative again this is Florrick
you'll get on she gave the judge but
they're their right to object and the
right to sustain the objections mrs.
Lewis whose idea was it to have dinner
Jennifer's or Michaels Michaels so
wouldn't that suggest that his attitude
had changed objection sustained
that one calls for speculation about
what someone else was thinking that's
and also phrased in sort of an
argumentative way she's combining two
different things together to try and
create an argument through the
questioning what she can ask leading
questions because this is a
cross-examination so she can say isn't
it true that but the way that she's
combining things together is an
argumentative way to phrase a question
and there it's a little ticky tacky but
the right to object and the judge is
right to sustain the objections when an
officer is referring to dropping
something in the pit or pitting it he
refers to what excluding it from the
crime scene narrative but that only
applies to irrelevant details we
wouldn't exclude pertinent evidence was
anything pitted it's not an intent to
deceive
any blame the prosecution will not come
out with every single possibility okay
okay missus boring none of this was in
the first trial is it your intention to
pursue a new defense yes your honor
so it's possible if a judge knows that
there's gonna be some contentious issues
that they bring the counselors into
their chambers and to discuss them in
person however it is highly unusual for
either the prosecutors or the defense
attorneys to yell at the judge
especially two lawyers yelling at the
same time at the judge you really don't
want to piss off the judge in a criminal
case where the judge is presiding over
your case and you don't want to get on
the bad side of the judge know what's
going on here Peter Florrick was a
corrupt and convicted state's attorney
if evidence was buried he buried it and
now she's benefiting from his knowledge
which still leaves you with some pages
missing here I'll give you till Monday
yeah if the prosecutors have hidden
evidence from the defense that is
totally improper if there's a missing
part of a police report or a coroner's
report
that's not ancillary evidence that's not
a tiny small thing that may or may not
be relevant to the case and also the
prosecutors are not the ones who are
allowed to make the call us of what is
relevant and what isn't relevant that's
up to the judge so they should not have
been withholding this paperwork that is
that is discovery 101 where the that
information has to be turned over to the
other side you can't hide the ball
against the defense like that that's
crazy I interviewed the first jury and
they voted 11 to 1 to confess excuse me
that's not true it was evenly split no
half the jurors switched their votes
when they couldn't get a trouble juror
to deliberate so I used my judgment to
change strategies
and was it your judgment not to update
us
[Music]
so usually in a big firm you would have
a senior counsel or senior partner
looking over the shoulder of a junior
associate handling a high-profile
high-stakes case like this criminal case
here here the senior partners don't seem
to care except that she didn't check in
down the line I mean you know you can
have it one way or the other you can
either give the your associate free rein
or you can help her and make sure she
doesn't make horrible malpractice
mistakes as she conducts this criminal
defense but man you got to choose one I
guess thank you state's attorneys here
now mr. north they're worried she's
getting this stuff from her husband
there are three images the middle is the
image of the surveillance from the 15th
the night of the murder and the one over
there on the left is image from the 14th
the night before the murder and the one
on the right is from the 16th the night
after the murder can you see the dates
on those I guess I can Jeff really she
wouldn't be able to just tell the
witness that that evidence is what it is
she would have to lay the foundation
that she has some basis to show that
that is the case you could ask him to
read the date stamps or I guess get it
admitted through the judge and get it
stipulated that that evidence is what it
says but you can't just say this is this
and this is another thing and get the
witness to take your word for it either
you have a plastic bag that blows across
your lot every night at 11:48 or these
are duplicates of the same tape
[Music]
that's technically an argumentative
question it's actually it's not really a
question I oh I understand sir
you didn't willfully mislead the police
yeah that's correct
no it's just that it gets cold out there
and sometimes you don't make the circuit
of a lot yes so on the nights that you
don't go out you don't record the actual
surveillance image you set your computer
up to duplicate the night before just in
case your manager checks it is that
correct yes oh snap
you got lawyers son is no recording the
night of the murder
and you were never there to see or not
see the pickup truck or the carjacker
I'm sorry
yes so a classic Perry Mason moment
where the witness recants on the stand
here it's not a criminal defendant but
it is the star witness and he shows that
the really important evidence has been
doctored and it leads to the defense
showing their case I mean that's not
very realistic just because it's so rare
that people actually do these kinds of
actions that result in improper
conviction but the kind of investigation
that Alisha has done here is good she
went to the particular crime scene she
interviewed all the important witnesses
that's what a good lawyer does it's like
an investigation so I think the outcome
is unrealistic but the underlying
investigation is good that's what a good
attorney should do and it worked out in
this case but not gonna find too many of
those examples in real life whether
demolishing the key prosecution witness
didn't just save your ass his first
chair nice work by the way Thanks
it was enough for reasonable doubt yes
she didn't just demolish the the
prosecution's main witness she showed
him to be an outright liar that the jury
can't trust anything that man says and
she has removed it a major impediment to
her case which is that the story about
the red truck couldn't be corroborated
well the reason it couldn't be
corroborated is because the
prosecution's main witness was a liar so
yeah if you're the prosecution you
should be really worried because if your
star witness has just been shown to be a
liar and nothing he says can be trusted
you should probably pick up your ball
and go home because that that should be
reasonable doubt right there reasonable
doubt is a very high burden and if your
star witness has just been shown to be a
liar and the prosecution might have been
shown to be covering up evidence well
that's that should be reasonable doubt
right there so I think she did a good
job and she has created reasonable doubt
she didn't be too worried about that
right now
mrs. Lewis did you and the deceased sign
a prenuptial agreement yes for tax
purposes so if the deceased were to
divorce you let's say in order to
reunite with his first wife section
sustained if the deceased were to
divorce you
you would be cut off from his premarital
savings is that correct action so I
think that's relevant she may not know
that calls for a legal conclusion which
a lay witness can't do but I think that
the prosecutors objecting on the basis
of relevance which I mean she's laying
the foundation for motive which makes it
relevant or counter motive of this this
other witness so I don't think that's
the right objection here also if that is
Alicia's goal here to show that another
witness has a motive to commit this
crime she might as well just come out
and say and and argue against the
objections say Your Honor it is relevant
because it goes to the motive of this
witness who is a possible other suspect
in this case and just come right out and
so she can plant those seeds in the in
the jury's mind that all of these
questions that she's going to ask go to
whether this witness could also have
orchestrated this crime so she might as
well just come out and say it because
the more time she spends attacking this
witness without the jury thinking that
she's another suspect makes her look
like a monster and you don't want to
lose that rapport with the jury so she
might as well just make the argument say
she's another suspect in this crime the
previously-unreleased trace evidence
he's also admitted into evidence the
crime labs finding that these grey hound
hairs were covered in a chemical
compound called Alcoa Tolan have you
heard of this sorry the chemical no no
neither had I it is a lotion it is a
lotion that is used at dog racing track
objection not an evidence sustained and
you might want to stay standing mr.
Browdy I have a feeling we're nearing
your smokescreen mrs. Lewis
isn't it a fact that a year ago at the
time of the murder your brother worked
at a dog track objection sustained
no further questions so number one the
prosecutors objection shouldn't be
sustained that evidence should
and number two Alicia should come out
and fight like hell so that evidence can
come in because if she doesn't get that
evidence in through another witness the
jury is gonna be told to ignore
everything that was struck from the
record which in this case was most of
what that woman just testified to also
I'm not sure why she's testifying again
unless she was called as a rebuttal
witness usually you have to ask all of
your questions for a particular witness
at one time you don't get to call her
back you know days after the first time
you get to call her back so there's a
lot of walking is going on here wait
okay so the jury came back that's crazy
because if she knows that the brother of
that woman worked at the dog track and
may have been the reason why there was
hair you would follow that down so all
the good investigative work that she did
at the beginning of this episode is
totally belied by the fact that she
didn't follow up on exculpatory evidence
it sounds like I'm guessing by the way
that they showed the police officer that
he's done their work for them but holy
crap
you have a possible reason why someone
else has committed this murder and
you're not following up on it that is
not good criminal defense work Chicago
homicide has decided to reopen its
investigation into the murder of Michael
Lewis detective Briggs doing an
admirable amount of due diligence has
confirmed that Cindy Louis's brother
Danny had access to his employers pickup
truck the week of the murder and the dog
hairs admitted into evidence matched
those found at his workplace so our
attorney in his radiant wisdom has
decided to withdraw the charges against
your client and pursue a case against
mrs. Lewis's brother isn't that right
mr. Brody all I need is a yes or no yes
good so the judges belligerence aside
prosecutors and US Attorney's are not
out there just to get convictions they
want the truth as much as anybody else
and in real life if I think maybe not in
all cases but probably in a case like
this
if the prosecutor learned of Truex culpa
Tory evidence and strong evidence that
someone else was responsible for a crime
as heinous as murder they would have no
problem at all dropping the charges
against this person and pursuing those
charges against the other suspect
prosecutors have wide discretion as to
what cases they bring when they end
those cases when they withdraw those
cases and when they bring those cases
against somebody else so it makes
absolute sense that the prosecutor would
drop their case against this poor woman
and then pursue the case against this
brother figure who it seems actually
committed this murder and there wouldn't
be this hemming and hawing by this this
prosecutor here he would drop the case
and go against the other person we're
done here
[Music]
we're done here good job Alicia
[Music]
thank you all right that was The Good
Wife that was pretty good I enjoyed that
a lot they are better on objections than
most legal TV shows the facts are
totally unrealistic this happens over
the span of like three days when in
reality it probably would have taken
months for this trial to proceed they
were calling back witnesses when they
had already been examined however a lot
of the legal argument that was made was
good the investigation that the main
character undertook was good she was
saved by the sort of deus ex machina but
still nonetheless a better-than-average
legal drama so I would give the Good
Wife a solid B for accuracy you're on
the right track do better next time
so if you like this video let me know
about what show I should do next in the
comments and check out this playlist
that I put together which compiles a lot
of my other reaction videos so check out
this playlist and I'll see you in the
next one